what do you want from me what do you
want from me
what are you wondering why do you know
why are you scared
[Applause]
hi my name is
[Applause]
i need big shows big ideas hey i have a
big one with click hello
whoa you know calloway clay callaway is
a recluse
no one's seen it for 15 years i'll give
you three weeks to get this show up and
running i
won't let you down sir better not or
i'll throw you off the roof
there's nothing holding me back
i have dreamt of performing in redshore
city since i was a little kid
there's nothing holding me back this is
shaw city not your little local theater
he's freaking me out
i don't see your tippy toes this is my
daughter portia she wants to meet
calloway big fan my sister is on her way
to meet him right now
[Music]
your destination is on the right on the
right okay if you
could just give me some dance lessons
you will be saving my life
how do i know that you're not a weirdo
how do i know that you're legit
he says that she's never afraid and here
she is
the star of our show rosita
oh my gosh can i try no no no no
she's afraid she'll never be able to
play the part maybe this is for the best
i'll write you another part
there he is clay calloway go away
don't you miss the music you just need
to play again no i can't
i haven't even heard one of my songs in
over 15 years
and for good reason
i have climbed the highest
mountains i have run
through the field it's okay
your songs will carry you
just sing what i'm looking for there's
only one way left to go
dream big dreams that's what i always
said right
[Music]
there's always a choice just never have
the guts to make the right one
about activating piggy power